before we go we love to play a quick
roundup truth or dare
and
we have julie hanson here from our
audience hi julie
hi julie
[Applause]
so what's it going to be a truth or dare
i have to go dare oh
all right we'll do anything what is it
okay so in honor of texas week drew i
dare you to lasso ross
giddy up cowgirl i've never lassoed
before
me either hello
um can you do it i think do i have a
is there a something oh my god there's a
road up here oh my gosh
this feels like a very stiff rope hold
on no
i have to put on uh protective goggles
which i think is
not a bad idea considering she's never
done this before
i don't get it
in the cartoons they just
oh also like if you watch yellowstone
does anyone watch yellowstone wow
god i love that show so much
i don't but i just i don't get it that
do you see what i'm saying about this
lasso i feel like i'm being set i need i
need something with more like give
a drape this is
what if you did it like a like a like a
jump rope and just
pulled me in but look at this loop how i
what
oh it goes behind it
there you go
all right lady perfect i'm not gonna
look all right
i'll be too scared
come on wait no break it's twisting son
of puff
god darn it wow good cowboy i'd make i
know i've cuts
and they cowboys really they hook like
they make it look so easy
all right all right come on lady hit me
get me
i'm sorry does this look like a lasso to
anyone
you got a limp lasso
all right ready
get me get me get me
[Applause]
listen people are only as good as what
they have to work with sometimes and oh
rossi yeah you booked a big one
fish oh
that was so fun thank you for that
challenge i know we found another talent
that drew barrymore has
[Music]
you